hey welcome back and look who I have
here with me today
Lenora I mean we need to do a video of
you really yeah I went on food yeah so
some of you might have seen Leonora on
my channel before she is a bikini
athlete and Leonora what are we doing
today we are gonna be meal prepping for
those who want to gain weight correct we
are gonna be doing that we're gonna be
preparing technically six meals yeah
together yeah
yes six oh I'll be preparing meals
enough of three days from Monday to
wednesday and Leonora
she'll be preparing meals enough for
three days as well from Thursday to
Saturday so be sure to come onto a
channel to check out that meal prep as
well so I know a lot of the time we tend
to you know prep meals to lose weight
but a lot of you have been requesting
for meal plan to gain weight and
typically really need about 1,600 to
2,000 calories to maintain our weight so
this meal prep will be between 2,000 to
3,000 calories and it's going to be
roughly about 2,000 ish calorie ish yes
so that each calories yeah so depending
on your body composition you might need
more right so shall we get started yes
so why are we making first for today so
I'm gonna be making breakfast which is
going to be overnight oats and I'm gonna
be making lunch which will be salmon
frittata with spinach and dinner will be
black beans coconut and rice for
breakfast the ingredients you'll need
are one and a half cups of rolled oats
about one and a half tablespoons of chia
seeds quarter cup of dried seeds or nuts
of your choice or goji berries two
tablespoons of peanut butter and about
one and a half cups of any milk of your
choice as well as three large bananas so
Lenora I'm gonna be prepping breakfast
so what I'm doing that you want to help
me with my salmon of course I wanna do
sushi because I know yeah this is going
to be for lunch okay I'm gonna be
helping you with this salmon yes ha yes
correct
okay so just slice it alright just any
way that you want and you know just lie
sit for me is whatever that goes into my
body it's good it's fine okay
I'm good okay as for me for breakfast
I'm just going to mix all the
ingredients into this container and then
I'm going to put it into the fridge so
oats and then just add all the milk in
and again with overnight oats really
it's up to you you put whatever that you
want into this make it your own creation
if you like flax seeds then add flax
seeds in it if you like other nuts add
other nuts okay I love goji berries as
you already know hence I always have
goji berries as well as peanut butter
peanut butter it's really dancing fats I
know I like fatty nut butter I would eat
it straight out the jar no slowly eat it
eat it spoon by his food but it's great
for those of you who wants to gain
weight because sometimes it can be
difficult to consume a lot but peanut
butter it's so calorie dense hence just
consuming a little bit you're getting a
lot of calories from it and just mix it
all up I hope you're doing your cubes
justice it's fine
main thing is is taste as long as it's
delicious yes and so no we're so excited
so now what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
close this up and I'm just going to put
it into the fridge so then for every day
every breakfast I'll just scoop one
portion out enough for one day and then
I'll top it up with bananas okay it is
that simple and this is your overnight
oats this is your sliced salmon yeah
are we ready to cook lunch yeah so what
we do in excess is my favorite salmon
spinach frittata
I've been cooking this recipe for years
you see Sam and I'm already in love yeah
it's so easy to cook all you have to do
is cook all the ingredients dump it into
the oven and then just wait that's it
yeah so for this recipe what you'll need
about 250 grams of salmon 200 grams of
frozen baby spinach 6 large eggs 60
grams of grated Parmesan cheese 200
grams of sweet potato have a cup of
cherry tomatoes 1/2 a red bell pepper as
well as half a yellow bell pepper 1/2 a
tbsp of olive oil 1 medium onion and
salt and pepper to taste
so before we start let's preheat the
oven to 220 degrees Celsius Eleonora do
you want to help me half the cherry
tomatoes of course I'm like I might get
madly persecution during my hands are
messy okay all right so you want me to
cut this like how okay yeah and while
waiting for that I'm going to boil the
sweet potato so I'm going to pour about
half a tablespoon of oil and I'm gonna
start cooking all the ingredients here
and Lenora do you want to help me beat
the eggs yes of course Jeff well that's
cracking I'm going to start cooking the
onions
[Music]
use your bicep - I'm using my forearms
I'm using my let's see what else mazing
I'm using every single part from the
shoulder this is have work on its own it
is yes it is it is you tight oh yeah so
now I'm going to mix the salmon in thank
you for slicing our problem look at that
I like you see better yeah it is and
again guys remember if you don't have
salmon if it can't find salmon use any
other fish or even meat of your choice
I'm going to put this in as well the
frozen spinach because it's frozen it's
gonna take some time to cook if you're
honest I've never seen frozen spinach
before it oh that's using it okay when I
was living in the UK you know when you
live on your own everything goes off so
quickly yeah and you don't want things
to just you know spoil in the fridge
yeah so then I discovered frozen spinach
and I realized that why not use it
because especially if I'm meal prepping
it's gonna go in the fridge anyway yeah
killin or can we get half of the rid and
half of the yellow bell pepper into sure
salmon mixture yes chef it's all
favourite isn't it bell peppers I know
love bell peppers so much of vitamins in
this beautiful colorful traffic light
mix hubs and spices sorry this is going
in my mouth there you go look at that
color mm-hmm I always say eat the
rainbow yes either don't we go everybody
that looks very ready yeah your salmon
is super ready cuz we're gonna cook it
again in the oven oh sorry
I better stop otherwise I wouldn't have
enough for today and now let's pour this
into this dish and then you're gonna
pull the egg hunt okay so this is going
in whoo
the best kind of lunch ah look at that
I'm hungry now yeah you know it's funny
babe so this is meant for three days why
you're gonna finish me one day I
probably like oh one day one male
possibly and this is also very high in
protein right now your turn eggs you
have a double whammy of protein here
you've got your salmon and your eggs and
really really good fats in there I'm
going to add a little bit of Parmesan
cheese so this is optional yeah for
those of you who do not consume dairy in
the kitchen stuff like this happen so
you drink oh I think that's more than
enough cheese now so yeah who don't
consume cheese or dairy products okay
this is optional I'm just gonna cover
that a little bit more very you know
it's pretty again alright that's enough
that's enough that's enough okay instead
this is going into the oven for 30 to 35
minutes until the eggs are solid ready
yes
and that's it
well she's helping me with the dishes
I'm going to scoop up the boiled sweet
potato and just let this cool down
remember with milk wrapping you have to
let all your meals cool down before you
even store in the fridge or bring it out
with you so for dinner
you need 1 can of black beans about
200ml of coconut milk 2 large potatoes
cubed 2 large carrots cubed to latch
tomatoes roughly chopped 1 onion chopped
half a yellow bell pepper and half a red
bell pepper roughly chopped 1 garlic
clove minced 1 tbsp of mixed herbs 1
teaspoon of ground cumin quarter
teaspoon of ground cinnamon half a
teaspoon of salt as well as 2 to 3 cups
of hot water while waiting for our lunch
to cook this is our final dish for today
dinner and I'm going to be your dumb ha
ha yes you're going to be my dumper
Budhia beans coconut served with rice
and let's cook as usual our favorite
ingredient everybody's favorite
ingredient garlic oh yeah yes garlic and
onion Tom DeLay is amazing
I know there you go okay get it off get
off don't waste it
oh that smells divine if I play too hot
and that's allowed that's a cook
slightly I don't have no one enjoys
cooking this is so much fun is even more
fun when you do a friend I know yeah
that's the whole thing you always meal
probably someone then first field
probably saw a video just so cool all
what I didn't campaign right I was by
myself with people are they okay don't
know mess this up right now let's put
all the ingredients in just okay pour
yep bell pepper okay potatoes and
carrots
so that's your good carbs potatoes and
even the carrots them yes veggies or
your carbs remember that yeah and again
with this recipe used any vegetables
which you like okay let's get a black
bean in greedy I know I love making ice
cream with coconut milk yes oh my gosh
and look at that please tell me we're
gonna say that yes that's cute just you
you out all right now water whatever you
do do not lick that mmm yeah you get to
do that water yeah mix herbs and spices
going in
our recipes are so lazy
yeah just healthy main thing is you want
to be convenient for whatever at all you
just want to make sure that it's
convenient for your life stop yeah and I
think we need more kappa okay go ahead I
love it making stuff stories I know it's
your recipe
hahaha taste some as well you're gonna
actually I let you put that much put
more you know I just loved okay I think
that's enough okay I love these things
cool and not just allow this to simmer
for 20 to 25 minutes and I'm going to
cover it so we're gonna allow dinner to
continue cooking and lunch is actually
ready okay I am so excited looks so
delicious this is so beautiful you don't
get to eat it just Eleonora nice and
cool down but can we slice oh yeah I
just cool down yeah yeah what does cool
down so let's slice it first all right
okay I've got my slice pieces all done
perfect
yeah right now let's show them no no no
not yet it will eat right at the end
okay she's like that's what why do I
have this helper that's why we come meal
prep because we just tend to eat yeah
and not like prep it for tomorrow so
while waiting for dinner to cool down
let's show them how we like to eat our
overnight oats right right if I make it
in a really large container I like to
scoop it out and then I just like to top
it up with one whole banana so then you
mix and match your own yes so you get to
mix and choose other fruits as well
right seven days I prefer Kiwi or mango
then I would top it up with any fruits
that I like on that day
check your meats if I can be worried yes
can you slice it for me as well so I'm
using the clean part of the knife just
give that to me it's ugly all right sure
and I just like to literally a banana
just fall off from your life
because it just goes into this nice
pretty pattern of its own okay perfect
beautiful leg so that's usually how I
like to have my breakfast overnight oats
topped with bananas and if you want to
you can even add more nuts and seeds on
top or even other fruits as well let me
know how you like to have your overnight
oats so this is breakfast okay and this
will be enough for another two more days
so for lunch I like to have this salmon
spinach frittata together with sweet
potato and as well as if you want to up
your calories even more you can have it
with half an avocado mm-hmm so yeah
that's one was love yeah it's it's so
easy to eat as well it's so creamy it
adds that extra 30 minutes yes to your
everything to everything and for dinner
I'm going to have the black beans
coconut with rice so again I'm going to
portion this out enough for three days
usually for my snacks I just like to
have nuts and seats and it's about 40
grams and as well as a protein shake 40
grams is per serving yeah okay as well
as a protein shake so the total calories
for all the meals per day including two
snacks is about two thousand and 100
calories this is our meal prep time so
again breakfast overnight oats topped
with any fruits of your choice
lunch and dinner oh my gosh this is very
good so yeah well then I just love
seeing all of it in in that containers
is an end this meal pen is perfect for
those of you who wants to walk up and
remember gaining weight it's not just
about eating lots of calories or eating
bad calories it's about eating good
calories and nourishing your body with
the right kind of food and don't forget
to do your workouts as well yes remember
food is always your fuel correct and
don't forget to hop onto the north's
channel is Lenore Lowe and check out the
recipe from Thursday to Saturday click
here click here to subscribe and do
check out more videos from both our
channels and if you want more videos
from both of us leave your comments
below okay nothing to eat yes we can oh
yeah yeah let's go I'm just gonna use my
hands for reals yes for real oh yes okay